it's funny because before we came on the
podcast we were talking about scams
people who and then I tell from onion
plow myself people saying you shove a
computer and we were talking about how
dumb do you have to be we getting dumber
you know like what the [ __ ] is going on
you know which we never really answered
we said we're going to answer on the
podcast I don't know if we're getting
dumber I think we're putting a lot of
trust in the internet yeah at times I
don't even like purchasing my wife
handles all that stuff but I don't type
numbers into a [ __ ] you know what I
was saying I think I need mail the other
day and the same that one of my email
passwords was uh someone I needed to
change it's like chicken click on the
email that's my name I put it in they
ask my email address I put in then they
asked my um for my credit card
information I was about I seriously
taken my credit card out was about to
type it and I go you know what there's
no email place that needs your credit
card to change your email password not
forget put it down like you know it's
like I was that close to being that one
of those [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] and no
you're not you're never that [ __ ] far
away we have to think about Lee said he
got the call from the IRS people yeah I
got that a couple years look at the
first year that I didn't have a job they
called me and they said uh it was like
an automated message and I like contact
your representative or we might
recommend you get in this attorney you
owe such an touch to the IRS and I got
paranoid but look luckily now is Google
you just look it up and they and like
the IRS even has a thing on their
website that says we will never call you
it's always going to be through the mail
because somebody they just they just
busted one of the places in India it's
what were they trying to do to you they
want you to they probably call you and
wanted it like have you pay where you
supposedly owe to the IRS sir
immediately all those cops are going to
come to your house and arrest you right
children they had to scam on 20/20 or
one of those 60 minutes it's [ __ ]
mind-boggling mind-boggling how much
money people sent like without even
[ __ ] thinking like really those junk
mail things like you were
samba4 on the air was like yeah I need a
few people saying some checks listen I
tell this story this is one of the
greatest stories I've ever heard about
the amount because it's like when I was
a kid there was a a guy named Peter
lemon jello nobody ever heard of Peter
living gentle but ABC late night had a
commercial the best of Peter lemon jello
999 disguise things always songs
something new Peter lemon jello is
[ __ ] Island this one same can you
please look up all the [ __ ] people of
the jello is I'll never forget this
Peter lemon jello was this signet and
nobody knew Obama also they had the best
of Peter lemon yellow and he covered six
or seven songs and like it was the
biggest scam of all [ __ ] time Allen
isn't was he made I think I have the
commercial players yeah this is [ __ ]
crazy but they did this other thing this
I watched this on like some TV show
fifteen years ago like HBO late-night
this dildo company put that out they
would have and I wasn't Playboy it was
another high-level porno woman about
magazines it was like a million level
one with chicks show they're [ __ ]
and [ __ ] like that
the back page they had this dildo that
came in water and steam and smoke and no
batteries you charged it they must have
had it was twenty four ninety five they
must have had two thousand dollars the
first three months or something weird
and then a couple thousand after that
what this company did they didn't handle
dildo didn't even have a dildo they
would take your money put into the bank
and then cut you back a cheque that said
we don't have yeah but the cheque says
it's from a dildo company no they have a
dildo on the check this is way before
the ATM machine because I'm with you and
going you convert it to yeah who's gonna
cash this check will donate at the
[ __ ] genius
so they made [ __ ] millions they bang
people havin some people reported it but
this was Pete 11 jello look us
Peter lemon cello - I love 70 so you are
about to witness a new dimension in
entertainment
[Music]
Peter lemonjon
[Music]
Peter lemon jelly a mood rock experience
called love 76 which yes Peter lemon
jello has created a new kind of man
that's both romantic than thing just
listen
[Music]
niebo English so you didn't with this
guy not really even exist
no lovely played nobody's ever heard of
Peter Levin [ __ ] China a lot of our
music I never know nobody ever knew
about people they just put it out there
at night and they figured it cost them
nothing to [ __ ] get the camera with
her song wrong yeah like song by heat
but he had one song we probably wrote
and he just covered and the worse is
like I do the Vegas who the [ __ ] goes to
see that guy singing people's songs
the guy from vacation I would never go
see that [ __ ] guy in a million years
which guy that that dude who [ __ ] the
mother in Vegas what's his name that's
been there for 2,000 years then he
thinks he's out with he was Elvis I was
just a [ __ ] slap Wayne Newton no with
that [ __ ] costume on I'm gonna pay
$20 to see Wayne Newton sing [ __ ]
Bible Tom Jones so let's get the [ __ ]
outta I don't have time for that [ __ ]
but this was all the little I call them
American ingenuity skaters I let it go
I'm [ __ ] smart to do it know when you
got the I thought I went to I took my
dad out to dinner no I my wife's my date
I took my wife out to dinner so we have
walked no more so I go listen the way I
will get mercy shoes here the baby gonna
pair sneakers that sleek is there or
we're still alive I saw all those things
that they saw on TV late night so look
you know of course I'm an see on TV oh
yeah us what do you really call that
[ __ ] I seen on TV no no it had something
for your wrist that you'll never use you
know like like the biggest scam of all
time is to self-massage it you're never
going to need it there's no self massage
I gotta stretch my arm to get the bottom
my [ __ ] back I'm twisting my shoulder
to massage that gun and anything's gonna
work none of those things work but don't
advertise you know that the company
brace that [ __ ] comes on at 9:00 o'clock
at night fat people there you know what
if I get that copper knee brace maybe
our exercise but you want but you'll
drop the 2095 that [ __ ] don't work at
copper [ __ ] knee brace nothing I had
one of those I didn't order from there
somebody gave me powers that shot in
order that she'll [ __ ] TV though
what's the thing you put in your door
that you do for you
and what happened well no I was I was
stoned and I'd taken an ambien I was up
the next morning this is a [ __ ] box
in my door
two days later there's a box in my door
with a [ __ ] pull-up machine I used up
to as literally done one pull-up in six
years